i thought in the beginning it might be a
kind of contemporary upstairs downstairs
story
and then jackie was very open to the
idea um so she she was a mod she had
been a model she's very comfortable in
front of the camera both she and david
were very proud of their project of
building the biggest house in america
david was very proud of his legacy
and so we started um as a portrait of
this family with the backdrop of
building the biggest house in america we
were a small crew we were four people
which coming from photography actually
feels big but the amazing thing about
filming there is we were working in a 26
000 square foot house so we could be
four people and still be a fly on the
wall so that was kind of amazing and i
was definitely reminded of that when i
went to binghamton new york jackie's
hometown and all of a sudden we were in
small houses and i felt like a bull in a
china shop and i would sometimes ask my
crew to wait outside when nothing was
happening so we won't overwhelm the
household but when we were in jackie's
house we really became a part of the a
part of the fabric of the house there we
could be four people we got to know all
the different members of the household
including the
nannies and the domestic help and the
other thing that was unusual about their
life is they were used to non-family
members going through all the time so
they didn't act differently in front of
guests they were used to staff and
gardeners and
extended the kids too obviously and the
kids too and so we became part of that
entourage we filmed ten times over a
three year period
and usually between five and ten days
and very intense days i mean we were
practically living with the family and
the thing about jackie is she moves very
fast
she's very unpredictable and so we were
always kind of running to keep up with
her every time
we went something completely unexpected
happened and something that really
made the story progress in a way we
couldn't have imagined i mean it all it
always felt like there was never a
wasted day
because something incredible would
happen and
um but usually very unexpected i mean we
actually just went for a mundane family
birthday party in the middle of 2010 and
then happened to be there when the house
went on the market and that was really
the turn in the story and then i did an
interview with david where he revealed
that he had never taken anything off the
table and had personally signed for all
the loans and so it was only then that i
realized what the stakes were because
before that even after the crash i never
thought these were people who had any
vulnerability to the vicissitudes of the
market because they had so much
insulation well i took the film to the
sundance lab last summer and that really
transformed the film i worked with joe
bieni who's edited a lot of verner
herzog's films and
he helped me kind of craft a new
beginning and actually tempt in wagner
music for the beginning and it gave the
film an epic feel we talked about kind
of references to shakespeare and citizen
kane and
the film got bigger in a way and
and and i thought when i came out of the
lab that it shouldn't have a kind of
documentary score but it should really
have a big score an orchestral score
which
doing a documentary we didn't have
anywhere near the money for but jeff
beale really fell in love with the
project and
had a great story himself because he
actually
lived in um a house that he bought out
of foreclosure a mcmansion that he
bought because he could have a full
orchestra play in his living room and
actually we started filming in early
2009
and at that time they were the people
that would never be affected so i
thought i was doing an inside view of
wealth and looking at the american dream
and how the house had gotten bigger and
bigger
and
also looking at a real cinema verite
documentation of a wealthy family
because most of what we see of wealth is
not cinema verite but it's very
constructed whether it's reality tv or
fictional and so to kind of get the
inside look and when
they had to put their house up for sale
by that point i had been photographing
the bust in a lot of different ways i
had photographed foreclosure cities in
the inland empire i'd photographed the
crash in dubai so when they put their
house had to put up their dream house
for sale it was very familiar and i
realized at that point that this was
really an allegory about the
overreaching of america and kind of an
epic super-sized version of what we had
all gone through and that really changed
my approach to the film but it also the
the whole tone of what was going on
changed too because in the house for the
first time there wasn't kind of
both boasting excitement but there was a
lot of stress and strain and dysfunction
and
and um tension in the relationships and
and i realized at a certain point that
it was david and jackie's love story and
in a way the house was kind of their
love child and looking at how this
that part of the dream fell apart too